foreign
[Applause]
I mean it's just crazy like I'm your
biggest fan I love you so much I love
you so much okay now
we met
how old were you gosh I must well I I
met you when you came to a yard sale and
you found none other than my extensive
Winnie the Pooh VHS collection I love
Winnie the Pooh
that's when I met you I must have you
made such an impression on me we met in
the valley in the Val and the 818 not to
be confused with the tequila company
which must be a nod to the area code it
is right yeah and it's on it's
permanently on my body and I'm afraid if
I have children and they ask mom why do
you have Kendall Jenner's tequila on
your body and my not my name it might be
a little bit of a situation later in
life and you still are passionate about
the valley I mean it's it's an amazing
amazing
going to the Galleria
okay of course I went to the Sherman
Oaks Galleria which was where
um uh Fast Times at Richmond High was
filmed so that felt really cool guys
there's a serious history at this mall
but when I entered when I would step
foot onto the Sherman Oaks Galleria my
mom would be like you transformed to a
different creature I'd be like bye thank
you for and then I said totally mom like
that's so nice to be like I'll talk to
you later like I would literally turn
into a full-blown Valley creature when I
entered the Galleria
um now I want to talk about Reese
Witherspoon yes
tell us how you manifested her into your
life
I've always just seen her as somebody
that I admire and like a far away dream
mentor and I always talk about it and I
I I don't know I got very lucky in that
she saw a movie I did and tweeted about
it and that spurred a conversation
between us and we got to make and
produce a movie called something from
Tiffany's which is on Prime video
December 9th foreign
[Applause]
didn't you like frame it I did you
printed it out and framed it I framed it
it was um it was hung up on my wall next
to which you mentioned my uh Beetle
friend my dead Beetle friend yeah not to
put them in the same category uh but you
know they're both very important items
to me Reese's tweet and my dead people
look what happened like you ended up
making this film with her something from
Tiffany's it gives me Sleepless in
Seattle vibes yeah
um it well okay we have a clip here
let's roll that and then we'll talk
about it
enjoy thank you so much I want a coffee
hot okay I'm just gonna get him I'll get
you you good yeah I'm good I mean I
ain't cheap but I could at least help
with coffee no no thank you but um
everything is just oh my God
going swimmingly clearly
Okay so
you're with this gentleman Kendrick
Sampson who is uh he's a hot tamale
right now and he
and he really is like when you're
watching this movie
I I feel like as the girl in the
audience like he does sweep you off your
feet which is really helpful you know it
doesn't hurt
um your Chemistry with him is so good
yeah he's the best it's so much fun yeah
it's really it's really sweet I'm so
proud of it I love it and it feels very
classic and Timeless with a little twist
in it perfect for the holidays too like
snowing in New York yeah okay Zoe at the
center of the movie there is an
engagement gone wrong something goes
awry I guess that happens in real life
you know
um like this moment oh my gosh does
anyone know this video because everyone
on the planet has been watching it it's
one of the most viral videos out in the
world right now it's insane so this guy
loses his ring because it goes overboard
and he goes in afterwards and the couple
is here oh my God I know
[Applause]
about their viral experience and get
into the details all right we're gonna
dive into it right after this
[Music]